[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos hoy
Israel aprobó el polémico presupuesto de
Benjamín netayahu que entre otras cosas
impulsará los fondos para los partidos
Ultra ortodoxos y procolonos Tenemos
reporte y chile acoge a la mayor
comunidad de palestinos fuera del mundo
árabe un Éxodo que lucha por mantener su
cultura a pesar de la distancia contamos
la historia de vida de tres palestinos
chilenos
Otro año sin gobierno en Líbano la
segunda vacante de gabinete más larga de
su historia desde la posguerra lo
analizamos con nuestra corresponsal en
beirut
iniciamos en Israel porque el parlamento
aprobó un controvertido presupuesto
bienal nacional y es que una buena parte
de los fondos dedicados a los
asentamientos ilegales de colonos y
raíces en la cisjordania ocupada como
parte del acuerdo entre el licut y sus
socios de gobierno nos lo explica más en
de este polémico presupuesto y sus
consecuencias nuestro corresponsal en
Jerusalén Federico cuevarberena
con la aprobación del presupuesto para
los próximos dos años Benjamín taniajú
consigue cierta estabilidad contentando
a sus socios Ultra ortodoxos y de la
extrema derecha pero profundizando la
polarización en la sociedad israelí los
sectores seculares califican este
presupuesto de saqueo miles de hechos se
movilizaron en la víspera de la
aprobación del presupuesto y cuestionan
principalmente los fondos asignados a
las comunidades judías ultra ortodoxas
de los 3.600 millones de dólares de
fondos discrecionales que la coalición
gobernante asigna casi el 85% están
destinados a causas de las comunidades
Ultra ortodoxas o del sionismo religioso
esto se traduce en casi mil millones de
dólares destinados a fortalecer los
subsidios para estudiantes religiosos
que están exentos del servicio militar Y
que en su mayoría no trabajan o también
unos 300 millones para las escuelas
privadas Ultra ortodoxas que en sus
currículas no tienen algunas materias
básicas como matemáticas o inglés todo
esto advirtieron 280 economistas pone en
riesgo el desarrollo de una economía de
Avanzada porque no brinda los
suficientes incentivos a este sector de
la población para sumarse al mercado
laboral Por otra parte desde la posición
árabe partidos de izquierda y
organizaciones cuestionaron los cientos
de millones asignados a los
asentamientos judíos en sí Jordania
ocupada que son ilegales bajo el derecho
internacional unos mil millones de
dólares están destinados al desarrollo
de carreteras que en su mayoría son de
uso exclusivos para colonos mientras que
hay cientos de millones asignados
incluso a asentamientos que son
considerados ilegales por Israel el
ministro de finanzas betzales motrich ha
anticipado que su objetivo es que la
población de colonos se dupliquen los
próximos años así el presupuesto allá el
camino para que el gobierno Avance en su
agenda ultranacionalista religiosa y
anexionista mientras en el Horizonte
vuelve a aparecer la controvertida
reforma judicial Que de momento está
paralizada y con negociaciones entre el
oficialismo y la oposición a un
infructuosas para alcanzar una reforma
que se consiga por consenso
pasamos a Chile pese a los 13.000
kilómetros de distancia de medio oriente
Este es el país de América Latina donde
reside la comunidad Palestina más grande
fuera del mundo árabe un Éxodo que se
agravó desde la creación del estado de
Israel en 1948 esta población lucha por
mantener su cultura pese a la distancia
veamos la historia de nuestra
corresponsal en Santiago Patricia Luna
Ana se prepara para salir al escenario
del teatro en uno de sus viajes más
personales descendiente de cuarta
generación de palestinos sus bisabuelos
llegaron a Chile a finales del siglo XIX
sus abuelos volvieron a Palestina y
regresaron de nuevo para sentarse en el
sur del país en 1930 la vinculación que
tengo con Palestina no es solo la
cuestión familiar sino que hace un par
de años y empecé a estudiar qué es lo
que pasaba allá en Palestina Más allá de
los familiares
y empecé a sentir muchas resonancias de
cuestiones
geopolíticas digamos del casi un siglo
después de que sus abuelos llegaran a
Chile Ana forma parte de un recién
creado colectivo de dramaturgos chileno
palestinos en su mayoría mujeres que se
agrupan por primera vez para conmemorar
la fecha dramática del naka mostrando el
teatro palestino en Santiago la
Palestina que yo experiencia ya la que
yo vivía ya
vive acá también a 13.000 kilómetros de
oriente medio en chile se encuentra la
comunidad Palestina más grande fuera del
mundo árabe llegaron como migrantes
económicos procedentes de zonas
cristianas a principios del siglo XX en
la oleada más grande y en menor medida
en 1948 tras El Éxodo desatado por la
creación del estado de Israel se estima
que hay entre 300 y 500.000
descendientes que ocupan puestos de
poder con su propia bancada política en
la fiscalía los bancos grupos
intelectuales y artístico culturales A
diferencia de otras comunidades
palestinas en América Latina la chilena
cuenta con gran implicación política
ya chicas ensayemos por favor Omar lleva
toda su vida vinculado al colegio árabe
de Santiago donde estudió aprendió el
idioma y el baile típico palestino ahora
lo enseña un grupo de niñas adolescentes
de manera colaborativa es abogado pero
dedica su tiempo libre a seguir
enseñando su cultura a las nuevas
generaciones en un trabajo de carácter
casi evangelizador que ha jugado un
papel muy importante en la resistencia
porque porque la resistencia al pueblo
palestino tiene muchas aristas entre
ellas la cultural en el sentido de
demostrarle al mundo que este es el
pueblo palestino estas son sus
tradiciones y que el pueblo palestino
continúa digamos resistiendo continúa
estando aquí y que en el fondo no nos
vamos a ir a ningún lado en las afueras
de Santiago basada a husein es un vecino
más en el pueblo de buin es popular
dentro de la comunidad llegó a Chile
hace 7 años como refugiado palestino
tras un recorrido por diversos países
que le nega ron la entrada por su
nacionalidad sin la vida difícil pero
difícil como otro Yo vivo como chileno
si hay comida comer si hay compras
comprar si hay plata hay no olvida sus
raíces ni sus costumbres tiene proyectos
de construir un restaurante palestino en
este edificio junto a un amigo mientras
espera la nacionalidad chilena para
tener un lugar al cual poder llamar
también país
pasamos ahora al Líbano que cumple un
año sin gobierno desde que el entonces
presidente Michelle aún declaró la
renuncia oficial del gabinete tras las
elecciones parlamentarias los grupos
políticos y los partidos elegidos para
el parlamento no pudieron improvisar una
mayoría y concluido el mandato de aún el
pasado octubre no se pudo formar un
gabinete sin un presidente un caos
político que se suma a la peor crisis
económica en las últimas décadas que
está asfixiando a la población libanesa
habrá una pronta salida a este caos
político nos lo explica nuestra
corresponsal en beirut etel bonet
el Líbano cumplido un año sin formar
gobierno en medio de la peor crisis
económica de su historia sin vistas a
que se pueda solucionar la parálisis
política el país se enfrenta al periodo
más largo desde la guerra civil sin un
gabinete en pleno funcionamiento al
vacío legislativo se suma El Ejecutivo
Pues no hay presidente desde el 31 de
octubre de 2022 con un vacío total de
poderes el Líbano se asoma aún más al
Abismo de la crisis tiene una tasa de
infracción de alimentos más alta del
mundo y la moneda local sigue en caída
libre
las condiciones de vida de los libaneses
empeoran día a día con más del 80% de la
población viviendo bajo el umbral de la
pobreza a la crisis socioeconómica y
política hay que Añadir la crisis de
Electricidad sin presupuesto para
comprar combustible la luz del gobierno
llega tres horas al día a los hogares
libaneses aquellos que pueden
permitírselo recurren a los generadores
privados lo que hace aumentar las
desigualdades sociales a los libaneses
les han privado que sus derechos básicos
mientras las divisiones políticas en el
parlamento bloquean la elección del
presidente y la formación de un gobierno
este domingo en Turquía se juega la
segunda vuelta electoral entre Rey Jetta
y perdogan el actual presidente y qué
mal quilisarolu en France 24 tenemos un
amplio cubrimiento Al Día de los
comicios y el lunes un nuevo programa
especial de espresso de oriente para
analizar el panorama político de los
resultados Pero antes veamos este
informe sobre el papel de las mujeres en
la sociedad y la política de Turquía
en las vísperas de la segunda vuelta
electoral en Turquía un susurro resuena
en los mercados de verduras de Estambul
donde decenas de mujeres se aglomeran a
diario como esta ama de casa
no hay lugar para las mujeres en la
política de erdoan según el gobierno una
mujer es una persona que debe quedarse
en casa Y cuidar de los niños Por eso
quiero que esto cambie como mujer turca
Quiero un cambio
temen la violencia de género sobre todo
después de que el gobierno de reyerta
allí Perdón se retirara del convenio de
Estambul en julio de 2021 un tratado de
Derechos Humanos para la prevención y la
lucha de la violencia intrafamiliar el
género hay mujeres que son asesinadas
casi Ninguno de los asesinatos es
castigado
pero el mandatario Turco quien lidera
las encuestas cuenta con un amplio apoyo
entre las amas de casa de clase
trabajadora
obtenga el
55%, 60% Incluso el 70%
lo quiero mucho qué más puede hacer este
hombre por este país hay mucha gente muy
desagradecida
para las activistas feministas turcas
derrocar a erdoan es una cuestión de
supervivencia Pese a que la alternativa
que Michael jaroglu tampoco era su
primera opción
como feministas y personas lgbtiq más
decimos que tenemos derecho a vivir como
queramos en este país queremos vivir
libremente con nuestra orientación
sexual y nuestras preferencias políticas
Pero sabemos que esto será cada vez más
difícil en la Turquía del akp y de
aduana
en las últimas dos décadas de mandatoan
denuncian han sufrido persecuciones
represiones y un amplio retroceso en sus
derechos queda por ver si el viento
cambia a su favor este domingo en
Turquía donde la sociedad sigue siendo
profundamente conservadora y patriarcal
y terminamos con cine por primera vez
una película jordana llega al festival
de Khan ishala avoy la ópera prima del
director jordano jamás al racid relata
la lucha de una mujer contra el
patriarcado y las injusticias en su país
Esto es lo que dijo su director
[Música]
y se inspiró en historia de una de mis
parientes
ella se encontraba en una situación
similar a la de la protagonista de la
película náhuatl
toda la historia se basa en la pregunta
qué habría pasado sí
la misma pregunta en la que se basan
todos mis cortometrajes anteriores no
doy ninguna respuesta me limito a
construir la historia a partir de esa
pregunta
qué pasaría si la mujer decidiera decir
No simplemente basta
no las costumbres y tradiciones No todo
lo que hemos estado acostumbrados a
hacer durante años
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Recuerden que tenemos
un programa especial para analizar los
resultados en Turquía el próximo lunes
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos sigan
con más en France 24.com
[Música]